[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
April 6th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
as if the frenetic pace of the Monday
through Friday work week isn't enough
working on the weekend is on the rise so
why can't some employees put down their
phone and their laptop and what does it
mean for the very real issues of
work-life balance and burnout wsj
contributor Anne-Marie chaker looked
into this and she joins me now hey
Anne-Marie thanks for being with us hi
nice to be here so Anne Marie is this
the end of the traditional weekend as we
know it it's really interesting we
looked at a big study of about 134
000 employees at more than 900
organizations which found that people
now work an average of 6.6 hours on the
weekend almost a full work day which is
up five percent from a year ago it's a
huge sea change as people make work
really their own and it shows a move
from the fixed work day to something
that looks a lot more flexible the
pandemic played a big role in this work
patterns have exploded in the past
several years and it's what many call a
work equation what they they want from
work and what they're willing to give up
in return has changed so you really have
this massive shift people are figuring
out what works for them and
organizations have policies embracing
more flexible work Arrangements but why
is the weekend work on the rise now you
know it's the trade-off for hybrid
schedules that allow for mid-morning gym
time afternoon School pickups dog walks
grocery store runs employees are moving
fluidly between work and personal time
in shorter bursts across all seven days
of the week all right but if somebody
gets an email from the boss say on a
Saturday afternoon does that put the
employee in a tight spot you know they
want to enjoy the weekend but they don't
want to be seen as avoiding the boss
especially when we live in a world where
we're almost always connected yeah
consultants and workplace productivity
thinkers say it's something that
employees have to be really clear about
so I spoke to a woman who manages 30
people at a law firm in Fairfax Virginia
she's a mom of three and typically works
three to six hours on the weekends
compared to one or two hours before the
pandemic and she said laptops and
handheld devices make it really tempting
to fill in work whenever possible so on
the occasions where she has sent emails
to staff over the weekend she just makes
it very clear to them that she doesn't
expect a response she prefaces emails in
advance like saying hey I'm sorry I'm
working today you're going to get a
flurry of emails from me but you don't
have to respond just because I'm working
doesn't mean you should so that's one
way of doing it another way is to just
set your email to go out on a Monday
morning so it's okay to write them up on
the weekend but then have them sent out
on Monday that means your employee might
get a flurry of messages on Monday but
it's better than setting the expectation
that they have to respond to you on
their days off so what does all this
weekend work mean for the regular Monday
to Friday work hours it illustrates a
shift in how work is performed across
all the days of the week the survey of
31 000 people in 31 countries showed
that meetings are starting later on
Mondays and wrapping up earlier on
Fridays there's also fewer noon meetings
which may point to people taking a big
midday break so I think work is
happening in shorter bursts and
interspersed with personal time that
we're taking across all seven days a
week okay but still this rise in weekend
work brings to mind all the talk of
work-life balance and employ burnout
which became very real issues during the
pandemic yeah so companies and their
workers walk a really thin line in
pursuit of this elusive work-life
balance on the one hand employers want
to avoid burnout among all the people
that work for them but they also want to
ensure that they're not losing paid
hours to Springtime strolls and visits
to the StairMaster and employees are
more protected than ever of their
personal lives as work and home collides
all right so if somebody can't avoid
week can work how can they make the most
of it so they don't get burned out I
hype of work really matters so if you
approach
dread this is a tiresome chore it's
going to feel less relaxing than
approaching it as ah this is my zen time
where I get to write and really have
some nice quiet time and make it more of
an enjoyable Zen task maybe take your
laptop outside it can make a huge
difference in how relaxing and restful
and experience it is all right that's
Wall Street Journal contributor
Anne-Marie Shaker and Marie thanks so
much for being with us thank you and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you